hey guys it's Justine and Jenna you
can't see her she's behind the stuff hi
you guys know that I do a lot of videos
about tech and a lot of times companies
will send things to my management
company or send me to review and I don't
get a chance to do them when they send
so this is what happened this is gonna
be a massive unboxing of a lot of things
and some of the things that you'll see
here I will be making videos about later
on but I just want to get them all
unboxed the last time that I did one of
these massive tank holes I gave away
some Amazon goodies to you guys and it's
actually really difficult because I was
like mailing you guys things so this
time I'm just gonna send an Amazon gift
card when I choose two people I'm not
sure which platforms so you guys have to
be on top of it on all platforms so on
youtube leave me a comment below tweet
me on twitter at i just seen and leave
an Instagram comment on the Instagram
photo from this video it'll be a
thumbnail to look like this a bunch of
stuff I'm so overwhelmed
I am too I'm not really sure where to
start well it's clear some space so we
can do this like one at a time it was
like Christmas
you also got this didn't you I did I did
a little Twitter unboxing you already
unboxed it did I even like put it to
like the Gears of War music oh my gosh
I'm so behind
oh god this is oh it also was very hard
to open that believably industrial but
you're doing a good job
Wow yes oh my gosh there's more stuff to
open yeah there's a lot of things in
here really yeah oh my goodness this is
so great I'm prepping the trash bag this
is for Gears of War 5 this is so cool
though keep going it's cute
ok we'll be having their surprises in
the bottom oh my why
it's really cool there's also this
really cool um figure oh where I love
this is the Xbox pro carvings fan I've
been using that actually it's really
nice
I brought a ways
I have a to station set up in my room
now so I have the new Xbox elite
controller and then I have that on the
other side this is really nice look at
that piece I don't want to like get up
is there a controller in there to match
yeah yeah so here's the controller no oh
my gosh this is so nice
also another thing for your teamwork yes
I have the Gears of War 4 on my coffee
table right now that t-shirt is by
Rockstar Energy Drink awesome I Seagate
game drive no wait this is nice oh I
know I don't I don't think I got a book
well they knew you don't read I read six
months ultimate game pass ok so I'm
gonna give this away to somebody also on
Twitter so pay attention to Twitter I'm
gonna tweet it out it's only gonna be
good for one person now so we're gonna
need a bigger trash can
so you take the batteries I do not I'm
another game pass mmm nice okay yeah I
guess I can give away to ever gonna turn
the air conditioner on I'm sweating
please wait because I'm wearing a beard
I'm you should always sweaty
have you opened the Xbox yet there's an
Xbox no you ruined the surprise
wait is there a controller in there as
well he's not pretty noise canceling my
god those are cool let me see like I
couldn't even a razor they all raise our
oh speaking of these these are not happy
those these are the kiddie edition and
they light up so kind of excited I need
a headset for my gaming beautiful I
still use my Gears of War for Xbox okay
you guys need to look how incredible
this is the attention to detail it's
like it's amazing zette that looks
really good
that's a Greg likes of winter look this
is honestly out of all of the X boxes
that I've seen other than the pinky the
one that I custom-made myself
Bragi the world this is amazing it's so
good this is unbelievable what an
incredible press kit well this t-shirt
is a nice quality too
I'll tell you what I get a lot of free
t-shirts from like offense the Xbox ones
are always incredible they're always
nice you're really great
ok so maybe I'll just clear out some
space and we'll open up the next thing
Jenna is putting herself into the box
you're not going in the box so I was
gonna open this boot this is Razer so
I'm gonna open this with all the Razer
accessories that we have so let's
continue on the Xbox train choo-choo
so I already know what this is I saw a
bunch of people already unbox this so
it's kind of like a spoiler but this is
a Taco Bell Xbox
Oh oh my gosh what is this okay so Wow
okay well this has a unique silver to
black hombre fade this green comes with
the new Xbox elite controller what
triggered the elite controller is
incredible
we've been using it playing call of duty
what it even makes the Taco Bell embalm
the sound when you power it on okay this
Oh
I love this because it's so super subtle
ombre okay ready oh my god oh my
goodness I can't even believe okay wait
a minute
is this the smallest of things have just
I'm shaking is this like one of those
things where it's like you turn on the
Xbox you hear that sound and then you're
automatically like salivating I
understand what you're doing to talk
about we don't hear the gears no no this
video is gonna be 25 hours long okay
ready for Gears it was over a frosty
crackle you're we might need to take
Jenna to the hospital okay there's still
more to this sandbox the elite wireless
controller oh oh my goodness the elite
controller you guys it is worth it
i pre-ordered it at e3 while we were
looking at it like this thing is just
beautiful listen here
this has enjoyed the new sport phone
controller xbox weightless
oh look at that hoodie hold on this is
all I know
oh that is sorry I'm Noopur nice it's a
little lemon oh I actually remember they
asked me for your size yeah why didn't
you ask me for my size Wow look how nice
this is
okay all right oh my gosh okay oh my
gosh help this is so sweet as o bobl I
love Lou the lemon that's a good color
it's like one of my favorite call it is
a nice color do you see thing over there
that's razor hyped about that oh my god
almost the kite was this so one of these
is for you actually well this is
something that I wanted to do a complete
video about but I ran on time this is so
awesome so this is like a microphone
that you can connect to the Razer
synapse app and you can add emojis on to
it I saw it on Twitter and I was like
this is incredible and I came over and I
saw it in real life and I was like open
it woman I can't try this out I'm also
redoing a little gaming station for a PC
set up so stay tuned for that videos so
now I'm gonna all these great
accessories deal with it
what is this over here what we have this
is the Chinese made the tournament
edition they're just really getting in
it it's for gamers by gamers yeah oh
gosh yes I did
so it's got Best Buy exploded
yeah baby
yes so the pink Roma it is in my head
awareness okay found this beautiful this
is just it is one of my most I think
prized possession and I will not even
joke but look how nice this fits in here
into the keyboard thoughtful it's super
thoughtful and super flat Windows is
updating great
let's open up as much as I've always
tried to like not like pink because
that's like a stereotypical girl thing I
decided I don't care what you think and
I'm going to like what I want I don't
really like pink
oh my fanny so these are yeah these are
the newest version so it's really cool
to use also light up and if you're a
streamer it will also react to your
audience they say which is kind of
interesting so the different colors will
change okay clean up girl clean up clean
up everybody
okay we're setting up the razor Huntsman
tournament edition so while I'm setting
this up do you want to maybe bring in
our next victim
what's like to gaming okay so I'm going
to be making a separate video about this
but I just needed to get off and set up
cuz this is gonna be great
it's so cute super cute so this is the
Sega Genesis meaning okay we'll wait
look at my ears are am i lighting up yes
I'm wet
wait a minute are these all the games 40
classic games plus two bonus special
bonus title I don't know Tetris
so there's 42 Sonic the Hedgehog Sonic
Spinball Golden Axe that's the tower
mini so I think this all like stacks on
top of each other all right there we go
a true fan this is gonna be super fun
it's also gonna be a big throwback
there's almost like a full sides as you
controller the controller is bigger than
the console okay what should we open
next oh my gosh
[Music]
this is cool
okay I use mine every day I've already
beat two videos love it really yeah oh
you make this video no way okay this is
what I'm most hyped about because you
can charge your air and what you have to
watch and your phone oh the thing it's
like if air power this is I'm traveling
with us now we'll have a wireless phone
charger air pods and I will watch all
the same time it's very convenient move
it on move is lacking unlikely No
did you say you wanted to open a box
with this oh so clearly we're going on
the iPhone case party these are the gear
for ultimate impact protection cases
apparently oh this one's nice this is
like
hello hello whoa I'll have you seen look
oh no God is a look mmm this is really
nice what makes you so special at Autzen
stylish cases feature a d3o smart
technology which is trusted by
motorcyclist sports professionals and
even the military these also was sent
and I'm kind of overwhelmed this has a
purse attached to it and like a little
wallet and a chain okay do you like it I
guess I thought I looked over and you
know like those measuring tapes for your
like need to measure something about
that's what you had on you I will say
the idea when I see people like I'm
wearing MOPP follow them like that's
convenient this is like fresh my hair
okay a trash bag because I have a small
OCD and crisis bothering me
okay would we got next my gosh okay so I
got you one of these me I was on the
Kickstarter a so long ago for the switch
pod you guys have already seen tons of
people open these up but they're pretty
cool so it's which pot I've won for you
we've also got from DJI Osmo accessories
I got pixel book over here so I guess
while you open that up I'm gonna open up
the osmosis trees so this is the pocket
waterproof case which I'm super hyped
about
this is for the Osmo for underwater the
Osmo pocket Oslo pocket ah definitely be
a weapon Oh
the expansion rod yeah this is gonna be
fun Janna I found this break we're going
an adventure
what do we have next oh I can't believe
that you bought these from me you are so
kind
I actually did buy these before me well
I bought them for my new office and then
I never ended up setting them up I'm
actually really excited about these I
tried to get them but they've been like
backorder i order them a while ago whoa
you can plug in three in one we did that
we did do that so when I am ready to set
these up you connect it to the hue app
which is great because you control the
colors you can assign it to room you can
then can I get your smartphone control
it right there's more stuff I'm gonna
get a little container to put all this
stuff in so that it doesn't get
separated a little stand east and see
it's very bright over tomatoes I know
you can't tell what's happening put all
this in there okay we've got a lot more
things here we do we're almost done guys
I promise
oh these are the sony noise cancelling
earbuds this is the new nest mini and I
have blue pixels look go thank you
I'm so excited
I use these on the way back from New
York and I really like them because it's
nice because they're always canceling
these are these seven ewf 1000 x m3
compasses I'm ready to go pixel book go
nest mini excited to try that neck is
updating its nice mini small and mighty
small I might even your small in my way
update two minutes away
gosh this bag is so nice it's made
exclusively for google oh wow he's
behaving a few new colors as well is
there anything else that we're missing I
think that's just about everything we've
got some updates that have happened so
this is the editor which is kind of
awesome because you can edit a little
emoji here in the little editor so
there's like J that's me and the emotes
shows up here until because you
basically can put anything on there if
you're streaming you can set up alerts
so that when someone subscribes or
donates you can have a do cool stuff and
you also have that happen when your
headset did my I did my ears change
followers what if we turned off the
lights
let's try yeah just hit that light ain't
that big boy okay Tess am i is my head
doing some things as it match this
everyone's shaking their head yes so on
is that something you need to be good at
games cuz I'm just distracted by the
lights I know right you can change it to
do like spectrum cycling oh you're out
pink am i oh this is so fun what do I
look like is a question do I look silly
oh look at this this is the fire
[Applause]
let's say this is probably other than
the gears Xbox I think like my favorite
I also think yours cookies well we're
not very cookies they're just trip to
the horn we have what the human who
cares it's so sweet of them
okay let's turn the lights back on oh my
god a magic razor thank you Xbox thank
you DJ I thank you Google thank you
thank you ever so do you think so only
oh my gosh this is an incredible
unboxing this is really the biggest
unboxing I've ever done on Sega Genesis
thank you oh my gosh take it everyone
thank you guys for watching this was
amazing and don't forget I am doing a
giveaway for a few Amazon gift cards
thanks everyone for making my dreams
come true
I had to said I might mix a book now I'm
gonna go okay bye sorry I got you so
long it's fine this hostage situation of
cookies so
[Music]